So, imagine that you were a programmer implementing the internal logic of
the clock radio. You would have to take into account all of the different
events, okay? And all of the possible combinations of those events.
So, ultimately, you have to deal with all those cases. And consequently,
it makes sense during the analysis phase, to list them all, okay?
To give a fairly precise description of what are all the different events.
What information comes in along you know,
its parameters to those events. And ultimately then, what the system,
how the system's going to respond to those events. And for the purposes of this
exercise, I've expressed that in a table in which we have numbered events, and
we have the the description of the event, and then the systems response to
that event. So, listed here at the beginning of that table